so whatever happened with ring I'm
working well right now oh yeah I'm
literally right now like literally the
phone call that I got off of was I was
lying a conversation about some notes
concert so what can you tease people
about status of the project we t you
know we are MGM and Amazon are
developing it and I am writing the pilot
currently Alan Taylor is attached to
direct and you know and hopefully that
will turn into a actual set of moving
picture contents
well the thing that with the Amazon is
that I know that they put more emphasis
on things that will possibly break out
you know like with the boys that
completely broke out front of a row they
have Lord of the Rings
you know so can you sort of talk about
how they're they're looking for things
that will be possible world builders I
have no idea I mean honestly I don't
know what before I do know that they
seem to like these larger objects right
that have scope and scale I mean if you
go all the way back to that initial play
with man in the high thousands that is
this one of these sort of you know it's
a point of view piece and I think that
these big comprehensive universes I
think they're very few of them still
available I certainly think known space
is one that you know for those of us who
are married image fans and in our high
school days or your case it could be
college because I'm seven hundred years
older than you but not really but go on
but you know no spaces Nivens world is
universe dare I say is so incredibly
complex and nuanced and written world
has always been this entry point and
everybody has better minds than my have
tried to to crack it but hopefully
hopefully we'll do it this